One of the oldest, most tired and
unsophisticated tropes of the American
right wing is calling anything nuanced, anything
intellectual, even simply something science based
gay, or sometimes they'll use the code word
effeminate if they're a little slicker,
like Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson.
And indeed, last night, Tucker Carlson
did a commentary about this entire pandemic.
And it was sort of a rant about how all these
Dockstader doctors and experts are telling us
what to do aren't the people that we should be
following and that there's something sort of not
masculine, in fact, about following people like
Dr. Fauci and Tucker devolves into the basest of
base arguments, which is that listening to public
health experts like Dr. Fauci makes one delicate,
timid and effeminate, which are just sophisticated
words for the right wing to say, oh, that's
gay man, that's really gay. And of course,
Tucker hides this by saying this is the view
of some Chinese adviser to the government. Why
Tucker cares what a Chinese adviser would
say when typically Tucker is denouncing
the Chinese Communist Party. I don't know.
But here it's convenient. And Tucker says,
look, the adviser says that it's a masculinity
crisis. It's effeminate to do this stuff. And
it's sort of like when we listen to
Dr. Fauci, take a listen to this.
Well, this tells you everything. In March of last
year, the leadership of the United States and of
China both declared national emergencies
in the US. Tony Fauci warned Congress that
re-opening American businesses could cause,
quote, coronavirus outbreaks. The government may
not be able to control going outside, Tony Fauci
said, was just too risky. Meanwhile, in China,
where the coronavirus originated, a top adviser to
the Chinese government declared that the country
was experiencing a very different kind of threat,
a more profound threat. The problem, he said,
was a national masculinity crisis. Chinese
boys, quote, have been spoiled by housewives
and female teachers, and they were becoming, as
a result, quote, delicate, timid and effeminate.
In essence, they were becoming people who
might listen to someone like Tony Falchi
left unchecked, said the Chinese government
adviser. The feminization of Chinese boys would,
quote, inevitably endanger the survival
and development of the Chinese nation.
Did you see how Tucker did that? He doesn't use
the word gay and he doesn't say it's his idea.
But then he says it's sort of like listening to
Dr. Fauci, the Chinese doctor, saying we've become
delicate, timid and effeminate. That's sort of
like when we listen to Dr. Fauci, when Dr. Fauci
as a doctor explains how viruses work and suggests
what people should do. If you listen to that,
it's sort of gay. That's that's the code language
that is being used here. This is just red meat for
the right. It's another version of the real men.
Don't go to the doctor type of sort of troglodytic
thinking. Now, maybe natural selection prefers
effeminate, timid and delicate. I don't know.
I guess we'll see who survives this thing, but
they're not even trying to hide their contempt
and resentment for anybody who listens to actual
experts rather than Fox News so-called experts.
Now, you really have to think about what the end
game is here, because it strikes me as illogical.
And what I mean by that is Fox News, his audience
is disproportionately older folks who we know are
more at risk of dying from coronavirus. If
Fox News is audience followed the advice of
Fox News hosts for the last year, many of them
would be dying. When they didn't have to die,
FOX News would be essentially killing off its own
audience, and it makes no sense in that context.
So the end game can't possibly be that. But it's
all part of the political movement that pushed
the anti mass protests for freedom promoted
Donald Trump's radiologist, Dr Scott Atlas's
views on a communicable disease completely
outside of his area of expertize generally
promoted, ignoring science on just about every
aspect of the pandemic. And it's amazing how much
things change and yet how much things stay the
same. So much has changed in society and culture
since when I was in school in the 90s and it
was common to say, Oh, that's gay. And yet,
Tucker Carlson, a 51 year old man in twenty twenty
one, is going right back to that same trope. Now,
one last thought, just as an aside, is Tucker
Carlson. Now the image of right wing masculinity.
And I asked that in a serious way. I don't care
how Tucker looks. I care about what Tucker says.
But is it now is this is the image that
Republicans now consider the pinnacle
of masculinity, a bow tie wearing sort of high
pitched voice, country club guy? Maybe it is. I
don't know. And I don't care what Tucker looks
like or what he sounds like. I care about what
he says. But it's also kind of weird to me that
he's talking about it's effeminate to listen to
Dr.. When I don't recognize Tucker as the image
of right wing masculinity that's sort of bandied
about at the motorcycle rallies and the shooting
ranges, I don't know. Now, just one more thing,
Tucker, in the opening also said going
outside is too risky. According to Dr. Fauci,
I looked and looked and couldn't find any
instances throughout this pandemic of Dr. Fauci
saying stay in your homes. I just couldn't find
it. So it seems that also, even on the premise,
even on the facts, Tucker Carlson is not
surprisingly, completely wrong again.